hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen on today's what I you
need a youtuber review we are going to
be talking about
kal-el now kal-el is a bit of an enigma
in the YouTube world she's pretty much
known for pulling her channel down
completely rebranding herself and then
putting a whole new channel together so
previous variations on her channel have
included information about cosplay
that's been beauty DIY fashion crafts
lifestyle advice quite a range of
information that's for sure back in 2016
she rebranded again and now her channel
is simply called kal-el in past videos
she's talked a lot about kind of eating
vegan and animal advocacy and her two
cats which of course we love seeing
animals and videos and recently she's
come out as no longer being vegan and
now incorporating some more animal
products into her diet so before she
goes and pulls this video and starts a
whole new channel or whatever I want to
take the time to review this video so
let's get started video show everyone
I've been eating at sure I'm getting
back on track with my health because let
me tell you the beginning of this year
was not a good year for my health but
we're getting back on track
I'm gonna lose the way to games and I'm
going to bring you guys along on the
journey so let's do it
I just want to say bookie has also
gained weight how many pounds that you
gained lady you gained weight because
you got upset that Rainey's here
speaking of Rini
okay so trigger warning obviously
there's some weight loss talk going on
also there's some cat fat shaming
so apparently fat shaming and weight
stigma is not limited to us humans have
a two different teas you have this
skinny tea and you have the quality and
they give you kind of like a little
schedule of when you drink what yeah
okay I just want to say that this tea me
company legit harasses me and emails me
every single week to collaborate I
haven't answered for a reason hard no
but anyways this skinny tea that Khalil
has got here she claims that it will
help to reduce her cravings so she
craves sugar less and can help stabilize
her blood sugar and the colon tea that
she's taking which sounds terrible the :
tea apparently can help detox your colon
insert iral here place ok let's talk
about this : tea which let's be real
it's not the most appetizing name I'm
not sure who in marketing thought that
went up but anyways kollel claims that
this that the colon holds on to stuff
and then releases toxins into your body
girl what does that even mean I have
said this in pretty much every single
one of my previous videos but you do not
need to detox your colon your body has a
natural detoxification system that is
working around-the-clock no tea no food
not even a colonic is going to be able
to do that for you and I've got a video
on colonics right here so you can check
that right out of course we can help our
colon out by drinking lots of water
getting exercise in eating lots of fiber
but any kind of manipulation beyond that
can often do more harm than good
now this colon teas main ingredient is
Senna leaf which is a laxative not
surprisingly some of the common side
effects of using laxatives on the daily
are things like dehydration electrolyte
imbalance and dependence in other words
you can't without it yes these are
derived from natural sources and when
consumed in normal amounts are not
likely to cause any kind of problem
however it's really important to know
that even natural products are not
benign so you really don't want to go
overboard next let's talk about the
skinny tea another must be real
offensive name but for a while now a lot
of these kind of skinny teas or
weightloss teas happy really killing it
in the
through social media influencers and
things like that but the reality is
they're just not a magic pill
kal-el mentions that this tea does not
contain any laxatives I guess she got
enough of that with the : tea but rather
that this tea is packed with natural
sources of caffeine based on the
evidence that we do have on other forms
of caffeine like green tea the research
suggests and in clinical settings the
combination of caffeine and polyphenols
in green tea may have modest impacts on
metabolism but when consumed in normal
amounts and like everyday settings
they're not likely to have any
noticeable impacts on weight loss one of
the main ingredients in this skinny tea
is along which is similarly high in
caffeine like green tea now the research
that we have on along tea and appetite
suppression is pretty scarce a study in
2013 found that hulong tea really did
not have any measurable impacts on
weight loss there really is not enough
evidence to suggest that ulong tea has
any impact on appetite there is however
evidence to suggest that drinking any
no-calorie substance whether that's tea
or water before a meal may help reduce
your appetite one said he found when
people drank two glasses of water before
a meal they consumed about 75 to 90
calories less so what about these teas
when it comes to stabilizing blood
sugars well a study conducted by the
American Diabetes Association found that
boolong tea may be an effective
complement to diabetes treatment for
people living with type 2 diabetes
however this study had 20 participants
and they were all taking medication for
their diabetes so I'm really not sure
how much it tells us so Khalil has
really never shared that I'm aware of
that she has type 2 diabetes so I'm just
going to assume that she does not so we
really don't know the impact of long tea
on somebody without the disease what is
recommended for preventing blood sugar
dips is to eat consistently and
regularly somewhere around every 3 to 4
hours and to combine your carbohydrates
with a source of fiber protein and/or
fat the bottom line on these teas is
that they're really not going to lead to
any kind of measurable weight loss and I
really think it's high time that
influencers stop promoting them
and the FTA cracks down on some of these
claims because they are super
problematic
please tini show me one piece of
evidence that suggests that people
drinking your teas are gonna lose weight
without changing their diet or exercise
regime heck I mean show me any research
that somebody can do all of those things
and keep the weight off
hey if you want to drink a cup of tea do
it I love tea I drink it all the time
but don't waste your money on these
fancy packages and outlandish claims and
these programs that just make you spend
more and even if kollel isn't using this
product for weight loss purposes she's
partnering with this brand and aligning
her views with theirs so that says a lot
about her brand and her channel okay
let's look at brunch what inspired this
was my love for kimchi fried rice but
I'm not about to wake up in the morning
and make that because that's just too
big of a production so this is kind of
like the quick and easy version of it
and then I also pour a little bit of the
juice mmm cuz if you guys didn't know
kimchi is a probiotic it's really good
for you and I feel like a lot of the
beneficial bacteria are in the juice so
put a little bit of the juice on there
and then transfer over my egg we just
put eggs on top like so and then last
but not least I put a little bit of
black sesame on top just for a bit of
crunch and added nutrition even more
calories so based on my calculations
including the tea Khalil's brunch clocks
in it closer to 400 calories so half of
that and for most people that is like a
light to moderate sized breakfast that's
really not a big deal I mean like to put
that in perspective a bagel with cream
cheese would have the equivalent amount
of calories having said that I am
totally digging this breakfast
combination I love that rice hack I'm
definitely gonna try that can I guess
those crispy bits on the bottom so good
you guys also know I
of eggs of course a really great source
of protein and of course that sesame bit
on top it's gonna add some really good
healthy fats I also love fermented foods
they're rich in probiotics which may
play a role in heart health bone health
blood sugar control inflammation
immunity even anxiety having said that
when choosing probiotic rich foods
fermented foods I definitely recommend
going to the refrigerator section
because sometimes those shelf-stable
options have been pasteurized which may
compromise the live bacteria having said
all of that that looks super super yummy
so let's continue on I'm terrible I did
not eat healthy food pretty much at all
I mean I don't see more film crew to get
all of your nutrients and minerals on a
diet that includes all the food groups
it kind of I mean it's common sense so
assuming you're not eating fast food and
microwavable food and whatever rate it's
I feel like I have a much larger safety
net that I'm covering all my nutrients
minerals whatever by including food from
all the food groups than just eating
fruits vegetables grains well I am NOT
vegan and you guys know that I've talked
a lot about that in my video here I do
believe that it's totally possible to be
healthy on a vegan diet that is assuming
that you have some nutrition in
education not necessarily going to
school but like you've taken some time
to learn about food nutrition and you're
focused on getting all of your vitamins
and minerals in and also in terms of
eating the right amount of food I am a
huge advocate for incorporating more
plant-based foods in our diet and I also
acknowledge that there are definitely
some health benefits to eating more
plant-based and also it's earth friendly
so that's great too however I also agree
with kal-el that when done incorrectly a
vegan diet can be very restrictive and
can put people at risk for nutritional
deficiencies which seems to have
happened to kalau so obviously
yes it is easier theoretically to get
all the necessary vitamins and minerals
when you're eating from all of the food
groups it's definitely not impossible
on a vegan diet it just takes a little
bit more education and dedication see
the nuts and now I mean I realized I've
gained weight and like sight now I
gained weight not from eating animal
products I gained weight because I think
eight tons and tons and tons and tons of
processed sugar and barely moved okay so
let's talk about this weight gain
situation so veganism just to be clear
is not a weight loss diet even though I
know some people do use it as such
being carnivore or omnivore or a vegan
is not responsible for weight changes so
I'm glad she kind of pointed that out
what actually may have happened is that
killall maybe came off her feet and diet
and perhaps she had been feeling so
restricted that she just couldn't help
herself but binge and eat beyond her
needs I'm not necessarily saying that's
what happened I don't know that for sure
she has not said that if she did I don't
know about it but that's very common
it's very common when people come off
any kind of we restricted pattern of
eating that they just kind of eaten
excess now I'm also not gonna say that
kal-el was nutritionally deficient while
vegan i I don't know that but she did
say that she was not eating well and one
of the things that we should note is
that sometimes when people are not
getting enough vitamins and minerals
when they are nutritionally deficient
weight gain is actually a really good
sign of recovery so we need to stop
thinking about waking as an inherently
negative thing when sometimes that's
actually a really good sign of Health
say it is possible that when you go from
being vegan to eating animal products
again your digestion might be a little
off
like a bad way like an upset stomach or
like unpleasant bathroom experiences
I've had none of that I was scared of
that but I had none of that
what I mean is your microbiome changes
when you go again so I actually got my
microbial and tested and without even
asking any questions they knew that I
was vegetarian or vegan because they can
look at the different species the
different microorganisms that are in
your gut and they can tell what you've
been feeding them so I had all of these
microorganisms that liked eating fiber
plant fiber so yes it is true that the
gut microbiome of somebody eating an
omnivore diet would be different than
that of a vegan diet research has
actually found that a vegan diet
promotes a higher count of diverse
microorganisms in the gut compared to an
omnivore diet now to mention plant-based
diets tend to be high in fiber and fiber
is a prebiotic which means that it
actually feeds the good gut bacteria so
it actually can help them flourish of
course somebody that eats animal
products could easily have a really
healthy microbiome as well it really
comes down to incorporating a lot of
those high-fiber foods like vegetables
fruits whole grains nuts seeds beans etc
I also want to touch on changes to our
digestion when we go from a vegan diet
to an omnivore diet because it's often
claimed that you know when you switch to
eating kind of animal products again
that you know your body can no longer
digest the animal meat or or proteins
because we no longer produce the enzymes
to break them down that's not exactly
true if you haven't been eating dairy or
meat for a while and you finally do the
enzymes that are responsible for
breaking them down are simply just less
active so they are a little bit less
efficient when you do rouse them back to
work the key is to go slow the same way
you wouldn't eat an entire can of beans
the first day you go vegan you don't
want to eat entire porterhouse steak in
one go when you switch to becoming an
omnivore you know an ounce here or there
will really give your body and enzyme
some time to adjust and very quickly
your
will cats right back up and kick back in
the high gear
is working obviously I mean wait but
besides that I feel like I would look
much healthier I mean the weight gain we
gotta lose a little bit of this but just
things like I didn't have a break out
the other day because of some products I
tried just now pretty much all cleared
up but like the quality of my skin looks
so much better I feel like my eyes look
brighter my hair stopped falling out
like all the problems that I was having
about my nails I'm so thick and growing
and like not breaking they were very
brittle before because all of these
problems that I had before are all going
away
obviously that I have a new problem now
the weight but the way it's fine I know
it will have actually come off okay so I
have an issue with how this little rant
has gone down so first
Kalil talks through all the amazing
physical and emotional benefits that she
has experienced as a result of changing
her diet and ultimately gaining weight
but then she lets the weight gain
overshadow it all and the only reason
she's ok with it is because she swears
it's gonna come off I don't really know
her case specifically I'm not her
dietician however I would venture to say
that a lot of the benefits she just
listed have less to do with
incorporating animal products into her
diet and more to do with perhaps that
she is weight restored and now
incorporating all the micro and macro
nutrients that she needs she's just more
nourished now so weight gain might not
be her new problem it might be her
solution is because I ate
you guys I'm like I literally just can't
have it I place anymore I thought that I
could be like I thought that I could
control myself and just have a few
things but no I can't because I have
moments where like I was saying earlier
I won't I'll be so immersed in what I'm
doing that it won't stop to eat now my
blood sugar will drop so low that I'll
just need something right now and I'll
just go and I'll grab a cookie and then
I'm like I want more I want more I want
more I need no the blood sugar thing
works I eat a lot so that it spikes up
so then it spikes back down even lower
and then I want more sugar and more
sugar and more sugar and sugar going
like a legitimate drug like I don't know
I don't think this is like stressed
enough I mean I know we've all heard
this but really the whole thing with
like when you put a like there was again
some famous experiment where they did
like wracked the racks chose to sugar
over the cocaine like sugar is it true
yeah it gonna be good okay so I'm gonna
do a whole video on food addiction and I
actually touched on it in a previous
video as well but I'm just going to
glaze over this really quickly for you
guys but basically I totally understand
and empathize with the experience and
the feeling of being addicted to food
that is so so real and that's like a
primal response the animal research
today has shown that rats only exhibit
this kind of food addiction behavior
when they are restricted and when that
sugar is restricted for them so in other
words it's actually not the sugar that's
the problem it's the dieting it's the
restriction and again I'm gonna go into
lots more detail I'm gonna tell you
about all the stays we have on food
addiction to date but I just wanted to
kind of put that out there what did the
doctor and really got that thorough
checkup I probably couldn't have
justified in my head he's starting to
eat animal products again but because of
that I felt like that was the thing that
made me feel like it was okay or that I
could tell my
the reason that it was okay so I'm
really happy that kal-el got some good
advice from a health professional and
that she was willing to take that advice
rather than kind of follow along with
some other health influencer but I also
think this rant is really telling about
how much pressure there is on
influencers and youtubers to maintain a
certain kind of health journey even if
it's not healthy for them or it doesn't
feel good for them
just because we're afraid of what our
followers might think or say please guys
let's support one another's health and
food journey there is room for all of us
to do what works best for us
[Music]
you guys would kill me eat a snack so I
am all about intuitive eating but I
don't think worrying about what your
followers might think is like a really
intuitive way to eat but also sometimes
eating intuitively it means eating kind
of proactively
because you know that eating a certain
amount of food or in a certain way or
certain types of food will make you feel
better by the end of the day that's what
we call gentle nutrition and I'm going
to talk way more about that in our
upcoming intuitive eating series but
kal-el also has mentioned a lot in this
video that she really likes to maintain
steady blood sugars and the best way to
do that is to eat regularly and
consistently so ideally every kind of
two to four hours or so and ultimately
something with some fiber protein or
good fats in there so let's take a look
at her snack
needed me reminded it should go back to
the basics of nutrition you know you
can't go wrong with some walnuts in an
Apple I literally had stuff to share
your addiction you guys I'm sitting here
eating this Apple and I'm fantasizing
about having those little cups of like
dipping caramel yes I love that okay so
I mean I'm all about taking it back to
basics and keeping snacks simple because
we don't all have time to make
fancy-pants snacks every single day so
looks great to me
also I totally remember those little
foil pack caramel cups that my parents
would like put into my lunchbox so
nostalgic so good but ultimately this
snack aisle all on its own is fantastic
it's got a nice combination of carbs
fiber protein healthy fats in there
everything's going on so a very
satisfying snack kalau my love listen to
me here just you guys know what I'm
gonna say right girl you are not good
for just eating a plain Apple and you
are not bad if you choose to eat the
caramel sauce every once in a while
let's move on cool so is there a tease
these bowls anyway Wow yes so we have
lots of lettuce about half of the
container like lots and lots and lots of
lettuce then I have some shredded
chicken breast and I'm not putting that
much I want to say me he like a cup
total right and the cats are coming for
me right now
okay oh man I'm gonna go in
some seeds I have pumpkin seeds quite a
bit honestly I really love States and
it's all a total GameChanger
you're not putting seeds in your salad
start it really makes it so much tastier
sunflower seeds
cranberries another game-changer her
salads dragon cranberries it's so good
then I'm gonna go in which is a little
sprinkle of some organic feta cheese
it's a really good combo more cheese
cranberries more cheese it's not like
cheese dressing that we just mix that
yeah it's quite watery but that's okay
okay so we have a salad and I didn't
show this bit because there was a like a
lot to show but she made the salad
dressing basically by taking a
store-bought dressing and cutting it
with lemon juice so that it stretches
out the calories I actually think it's a
really great hack not so much to save
calories but just to add that little
added zip and brightness to kind of a
flat boring basic store about dressing
so kind of fun anyway the sound looks
pretty great I mean it's it's called my
favorite foods in it though I think it's
a little light on the substance
especially for dinner I would definitely
want to throw in some like quinoa in
there I know she mentioned sometimes she
adds avocado
throw that in girl I would just need a
lot more for dinner I mean I would eat
all that and like some soup and bread on
the side that just means ebay for a
couple of minutes because it's a little
strong so I'm gonna just let that sit
you can see it's already turning dark
really fast I don't look at say just for
a couple minutes and take her out I'm
just gonna sit my teeth
and watch something on TV and packs out
that was sad that was disappointing I'm
hungry Wow I was really hoping to see
you no more snacks and and meals less :
t this girl probably has more coming out
after that teeth and she does going in
so on that note let's take a look at the
macros Sokol Elle's total calorie intake
clocks in around a thousand forty six
calories she's got about 43 percent of
her calories coming from fat 36 percent
from carbs and 21 percent from protein I
am pretty concerned with kal-el's low
calorie intake I I don't know if this is
in an effort to combat the alleged
weight gain or if it's intentional or
not intentional I really don't know but
it's low like starvation low as for her
macros it looks like clouds following a
higher fat lower carb moderate protein
diet and if that works for her great
however I just want to note that she was
talking a lot about this alleged sugar
addiction and it's very possible that
that feeling and that perception may be
a result of kind of carb restriction in
general I am also very concerned about
her micro nutrient intake especially
because she talked about her history of
nutritional deficiencies so I am seeing
not a lot of vitamin D and calcium
there's not a whole lot of food sources
there I'm hoping she's taking a
supplement but she doesn't mention it
and those two things taken together
could put her at risk of kind of bone
health issues she's also looking pretty
low on folate vitamin b12 magnesium I
mean she was eating foods that have
these nutrients but because she's just
eating so little she's only having like
two meals in the day it just doesn't
give her a whole lot of opportunities to
actually meet those needs so I'm hoping
she's taking a multivitamin she doesn't
mention it but it would definitely be a
good place to start or just eat more
food I mean there's that too so here's
what I like about Cole Elle's diet
number one her honesty and openness so
Khalil obviously is quite open about her
experience kind of walking away from a
peak
diet and I can tell that it was very
hard for her to share this with
reviewers especially when they're
expecting plant-based or vegan content I
have my own experience I mean own
thoughts about this which you can watch
my video right here but I like that
kal-el talks about seeking out the
advice of a doctor or a health care
provider and that she talks about not
wanting to denounce veganism or
criticize veganism but just pointing out
that it just didn't really work for her
this really speaks to how individualized
nutrition really is and I hope that
people who are watching at home will
re-examine their own health and
understand how individualized and unique
their body is before critiquing others
online I also like that her meals are
simple and well balanced I really like
that all of Khalil's meals and snacks
are easy they're accessible there's no
hard to find or expensive ingredients
going on and honestly I was even
inspired by that whole rice cake
situation that looked awesome here's
what I think that kollel can improve on
number one ditch the tea propaganda and
misinformation
well Colella did include a disclaimer
that said she's not drinking the tea for
weight loss purposes she's still
aligning herself with a brand and a
company that makes money off of baseless
claims and targeting mostly women who
want to lose weight and detox their body
hard pass on that number two she's
definitely not getting enough calories
okay so I'm really hoping this is just
like a one-off thing because ultimately
when you're eating intuitively every day
could look different however if this is
on par with her usual regime when it
comes to calories consumed I would
definitely be concerned with micro and
macro nutrient deficiencies and also
with long-term impacts to her metabolic
and reproductive health in this video
Clell only has a few cups of tea and
then has brunch and then waits six whole
hours before having a modest snack and I
know she talks a lot about maintaining
you know blood sugar control and
stabilizing her blood sugars and the
best way to do that is to actually eat
more consistently and regularly so you
don't get those spikes and dips in your
blood sugar if
rice-based meals making her feel too
full I would suggest cutting it into
some smaller more frequent meals and
then of course including more
concentrated sources of calories like
avocado nut butter more seeds things
like that
and finally her language around weight
and beauty so throughout the video Clell
makes a lot of comments about you know
the weight gain being a negative side
effect of her just getting healthy like
I mentioned before if Clell did gain
weight it might actually be because her
body desperately needed to she also
talks a lot about having you know
multiple cosmetic surgeries and the fact
that the only reason she's mad about
people saying she had Botox is because
she believes it's an unattractive look
listen I don't care about your Botox or
your plastic surgery you do you whatever
makes you feel good amazing however as a
role model and an influencer to a lot of
young women and girls at home I think we
just have a responsibility to be a lot
more cognizant of these kinds of
conversations normalizing the
manipulation of our bodies with skinny
T's and colon cleanses and the
manipulation of our face through plastic
surgery is largely a result of social
media and as a female influencer I feel
a lot of responsibility to try to change
that culture rather than perpetuate it
and I get that it's hard like it's
really [ __ ] hard and as faces in the
media we are at more risk of criticism
but we need to use our power to at least
try in conclusion I think that kollel is
brutally honest with her viewers and
really fun to watch however as an
influencer with almost 2 million
subscribers I really think she's got
such a responsibility to pay close
attention to the messages that she's
putting out there into the world kal-el
you have so much power to change the
status quo and I'm hoping that with time
you will make peace with your own body
and help other women do the same so
everyone I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some other
youtubers that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]